Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想快速向大家介绍一件令人兴奋的事情。如果你曾经想过如何创造为你工作的收入，而不是不断地用时间换金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“循环收入竞赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. How do you tell the difference between someone who is sane and someone who isn't? What
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有由Lisa本人直接提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会告诉你所有细节。好了，让我们开始今天的节目。你如何区分一个人是否神志正常？如果
if the system itself can't even tell? In the 1970s, a daring experiment put mental health institutions to the test and the results shook the psychiatric world. Today, we are exploring what's known as the Rosenhan experiment and uncovering what it taught us then and now about perception, diagnosis and mental health. Hi, I'm Dr Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. Welcome along. In today's episode, we are diving into one of the most iconic and controversial studies in psychology. That is David Rosenhan's On Being Sane in Insane Places. And honestly, since I first learned about this study when I was in my A-levels, that name has stuck with me.
连系统本身都无法分辨呢？在20世纪70年代，一项大胆的实验对精神卫生机构进行了测试，其结果震撼了整个精神病学界。今天，我们将探讨著名的“罗森汉恩实验”（Rosenhan experiment），并揭示它在当时及现在对感知、诊断和心理健康带来的启示。你好，我是临床心理学家Marianne Trent博士。欢迎收听。在今天的节目中，我们将深入探讨心理学中最具标志性和争议性的研究之一，即大卫·罗森汉恩的《精神错乱场所中的神志正常》（On Being Sane in Insane Places）。老实说，自从我在A-level课程中第一次了解到这项研究，这个名字就一直印在我的脑海里。
It really is iconic. And that's because this experiment challenged the very foundations of psychiatric diagnosis and revealed somewhat uncomfortable truths at times about how mental health care was being practiced. We are going to be breaking down what happened, what it means and how it's still relevant today. Let's dive in. The experiment, what happened? So it was 1973 and David Rosenhan, who's a psychologist and professor, set out to answer a bold question. Can mental health professionals reliably distinguish between what he was calling sanity and insanity. To test this, Rosenhan recruited eight pseudo-patients, which incidentally did actually include himself. These people were from various professions, including psychologists, even a psychiatrist, a housewife, a painter,
它确实非常经典。这是因为该实验挑战了精神病学诊断的基础，并揭示了当时精神卫生保健实践中一些令人不安的真相。我们将剖析发生了什么、这意味着什么，以及它在今天依然有何意义。让我们开始吧。实验过程是怎样的？那是1973年，心理学家兼教授大卫·罗森汉恩试图回答一个大胆的问题：精神卫生专业人员能否可靠地分辨出他所谓的“神志正常”与“精神错乱”。为了测试这一点，罗森汉恩招募了八名伪病人，顺便提一下，其中也包括他自己。这些人来自各种职业，包括心理学家、甚至还有一位精神科医生、一位家庭主妇、一位画家，
and what they were tasked with was to all pretend to experience one symptom. In this case, he asked them to report that they were hearing voices and that these voices said thud, empty or hollow. Rosenhan specifically chose those words because he thought they didn't align with any known psychiatric symptoms at that time. They weren't commonly reported words for any diagnosis. So what happened? What were the results? Well, all eight were admitted to inpatient hospitals and most of them were diagnosed with schizophrenia. The study really began though when they had managed to get themselves admitted to those psychiatric hospitals
他们的任务是假装出现一种症状。在这种情况下，他要求他们报告说自己听到了声音，这些声音说的是“砰”、“空”或“空洞”。罗森汉恩特意选择了这些词，因为他认为它们与当时已知的任何精神病症状都不吻合。这些词在任何诊断中都不常见。那么结果如何呢？这八个人全部被收治入院，且大多数被诊断为精神分裂症。然而，这项研究真正的开始是在他们成功进入这些精神病院之后，
thereafter the patients the pseudo patients i should say were asked to behave completely normally they didn't report any additional symptoms they answered all questions that were asked to them and they seem to have stopped experiencing those auditory hallucinations so how long were they in there for? Well, the average length of stay was 19 days, but with one person even staying for 52 days. Despite acting sane inside the hospitals, none of the staff identified them as imposters. But interestingly, many of the real patients did suspect that they weren't truly ill. They would say things to them like, you're not crazy, are you?
此后，这些伪病人被要求表现得完全正常。他们不再报告任何额外症状，回答了所有被问到的问题，并且似乎停止了听觉幻觉。那么他们在里面待了多久呢？平均住院时间为19天，甚至有人待了52天。尽管他们在医院里表现正常，但没有工作人员认出他们是冒充者。但有趣的是，许多真正的病人怀疑他们并没有真正生病。他们会问：“你不是疯子，对吧？”
And I'm sorry if any of the language in this video is triggering. It's the language that was used in the 1970s at the time. Psychological insights. What did we learn? One, the power of labels. Once the pseudo patients were labeled with a psychiatric diagnosis, everything else they did was interpreted through that lens.
如果这段视频中的某些语言让你感到不适，我深表歉意。这些是20世纪70年代当时使用的语言。心理学洞察：我们学到了什么？第一，标签的力量。一旦伪病人被贴上精神病诊断的标签，他们所做的一切都会通过这个视角被解读。
For example, they were asked to record their notes of what was going on in the hospital, that that note-taking, that just writing things down in a journal, in a diary, was described as pathological writing behaviour. That's like you writing notes in a meeting or in a supervision or writing a diary or a journal. But these normal actions that many of us still do, even to this day, were reframed to fit the diagnosis. They saw what they wanted to see and interpreted it accordingly. Two, confirmation bias. Staff members' expectations influenced how they perceived the
例如，他们被要求记录医院里发生的事情，而这种记笔记的行为——仅仅是在日记或笔记本上写东西——被描述为“病态书写行为”。这就像你在会议或督导中做笔记，或者写日记一样。但这些我们许多人至今仍在做的正常行为，却被重新定义以符合诊断。他们只看到了他们想看到的东西，并据此进行了解读。第二，确认偏误。工作人员的期望影响了他们对
pseudo-patients. They saw what they expected to see, which is symptoms of mental illness, and dismissed any evidence that seemed to contradict their assumptions or their beliefs. 3. Dehumanisation in psychiatric care. Many of the pseudo-patients reported feeling ignored or treated dismissively. It seemed that doctors and nurses often seemed to avoid direct interactions with the pseudo-patients, which highlighted what we call the depersonalisation that can seem to occur in institutional settings at times. The fallout and the controversy. The study's publication caused somewhat of a furore in the psychiatric community. It seemed to reveal cracks in the reliability of psychiatric diagnoses and raised questions about how patients were being treated at that time.
伪病人的看法。他们看到了他们期望看到的东西，即精神疾病的症状，并忽略了任何似乎与他们的假设或信念相矛盾的证据。第三，精神卫生保健中的非人性化。许多伪病人报告说感到被忽视或受到轻视。医生和护士似乎经常避免与伪病人直接互动，这突显了我们在机构环境中偶尔会出现的“去人格化”现象。后果与争议：该研究的发表在精神病学界引起了轩然大波。它似乎揭示了精神病诊断可靠性方面的裂痕，并引发了关于当时患者如何被对待的质疑。
Following on from the study, one hospital actually challenged Rosenhan to send more pseudo-patients, claiming that they could identify them. Over a period of weeks, the staff flagged 41, yes 41, individuals as imposters. The twist in the tale? Rosenhan hadn't sent anyone. Whilst the study was groundbreaking, it wasn't without criticism. Some argued that the lack of transparency in the methodology used made the results hard to replicate. Others believed the study unfairly undermined trust in psychiatric professionals who were doing their best with the knowledge and tools available at the time. I think an additional consideration would be the waste of psychiatric professionals' time, money and resources too. Modern relevance, why does it matter today?
研究之后，一家医院甚至挑战罗森汉恩，要求他派遣更多的伪病人，声称他们能够识别出来。在几周的时间里，工作人员标记了41名（没错，是41名）冒充者。故事的反转是：罗森汉恩根本没有派任何人去。虽然这项研究具有开创性，但并非没有批评。一些人认为，方法论缺乏透明度使得结果难以复制。另一些人则认为，这项研究不公平地削弱了人们对当时尽其所能利用现有知识和工具的精神科专业人员的信任。我认为另一个考虑因素是，这浪费了精神科专业人员的时间、金钱和资源。现代意义：为什么它在今天仍然重要？
Firstly, it gives us food for thought about diagnosis terms and really the ethics of diagnosis as a standalone way of understanding people and the difficulties that they experience. So of course while psychiatric diagnosis has come a long way since the 1970s we've got more refined criteria and tools like the ICD-11 and the DSM-5. However challenges do remain particularly in recognizing the complexity of mental health and avoiding over-reliance on labels. Alternative approaches to psychiatric diagnosis, such as the Power Threat Meaning Framework
首先，它让我们对诊断术语以及作为理解个人及其所经历困难的独立方式的诊断伦理进行了思考。当然，虽然自20世纪70年代以来，精神病诊断已经取得了长足进步，我们有了更完善的标准和工具，如ICD-11和DSM-5。然而，挑战依然存在，特别是在认识心理健康的复杂性以及避免过度依赖标签方面。针对精神病诊断的替代方法，例如“权力、威胁、意义框架”（Power Threat Meaning Framework），
by Lucy Johnston and Mary Boyle, have also been posited. And if you'd like to learn more about the Power Threat Meaning Framework, please do check out episode 21 of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast, where I chat with Lucy herself. I will link that in the show notes for this episode. Secondly, we've got stigma and misdiagnosis. The study reminds us of the stigma that can come with mental health labels. It also highlights the importance of second opinions and patient-centred care to reduce the risk of misdiagnosis. Of course, what we know in modern psychiatric care is it can be very hard to get labels and diagnoses overturned at a later stage, and that that stigma and that belief about
由Lucy Johnston和Mary Boyle提出。如果你想了解更多关于“权力、威胁、意义框架”的信息，请查看《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）第21期，我与Lucy本人进行了交流。我会在本期节目的展示说明中附上链接。其次，我们面临着污名化和误诊的问题。这项研究提醒我们，精神健康标签可能带来的污名。它还强调了寻求第二意见和以患者为中心的护理对于降低误诊风险的重要性。当然，我们现代精神卫生保健所知的是，在后期推翻标签和诊断是非常困难的，而那种污名和那种信念，
you can follow you around, perhaps throughout your life. Thirdly, we have the implications beyond mental health. The insights from this study beyond psychiatry are that they apply to any field where labels and first impressions influence decisions. This is around in education, in criminal justice or employment, maybe even social groups and families too. It really is a call for us to approach every situation with empathy and critical thinking. And our fourth point, in terms of modern psychology studies, it's also informed our ethical practices and our procedures and gives us food for thought about the generalizability of research too. Before we wrap up, if you are enjoying this episode, you might also love my recent deep dive into the story of
可能会伴随你一生。第三，我们有超越心理健康的影响。这项研究在精神病学之外的见解适用于任何标签和第一印象影响决策的领域。这存在于教育、刑事司法或就业中，甚至可能存在于社交群体和家庭中。这确实呼吁我们以同理心和批判性思维来对待每一种情况。第四点，就现代心理学研究而言，它也为我们的伦理实践和程序提供了参考，并让我们对研究的普遍性进行了思考。在结束之前，如果你喜欢这一集，你可能也会喜欢我最近对以下故事的深入探讨：
Phineas Gage, the man whose brain injury involving a large spike through his brain revolutionized our understanding of personality and behavior. I also recently covered the Milgram experiment where people administered massive electric shocks to people because they were told to so don't miss that one either and I would love it if you would let me know which topics you'd like me to cover in future. Do let me know in the comments. Conclusion, what can we take away? Well, the Rosenhan experiment
菲尼亚斯·盖奇（Phineas Gage），那个因一根大铁钉穿过大脑而改变了我们对人格和行为理解的人。我最近还介绍了米尔格拉姆实验（Milgram experiment），人们因为被告知而对他人施加了巨大的电击，所以千万不要错过那一集。如果你能告诉我你希望我在未来涵盖哪些主题，我会很高兴。请在评论中告诉我。结论：我们能得到什么启示？嗯，罗森汉恩实验
wasn't just a test of psychiatric diagnosis. It was a bold challenge to the way we perceive and treat mental illness. It reminds us that labels can shape reality and that empathy and understanding should always guide our approach to mental health care. So what do you think of Rosenhan's study? Was it a necessary wake-up call or do you think it crossed ethical lines? Do you think you would have been able to talk yourself in or out of psychiatric hospital in the 1970s. Do let me know in the
不仅仅是对精神病诊断的测试。它是对我们感知和对待精神疾病方式的大胆挑战。它提醒我们，标签可以塑造现实，同理心和理解应该始终指导我们对待精神卫生保健的方式。那么，你对罗森汉恩的研究有什么看法？这是一个必要的警钟，还是你认为它越过了伦理界限？你认为自己在20世纪70年代能说服自己进入或离开精神病院吗？请在
comments below or come and chat with me on my socials where I am Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If this has whet your appetite for psychology, please do check out the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book. Come and join my free Facebook group for aspiring psychologists, the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. And if it's your time and you're ready for the next step in your mental health career, please do check out the Aspiring Psychologist membership, where we are doing wonderful things looking at research, cognitive behavioral therapy, reflection, interview skills, application skills, and so much more.
下方的评论区告诉我，或者来我的社交媒体上与我聊天，我在所有平台上都是Dr. Marianne Trent。如果这激发了你对心理学的兴趣，请查看《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）一书和《有抱负的心理学家集体》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective）一书。加入我为有抱负的心理学家提供的免费Facebook群组：Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent。如果时机成熟，你准备好在心理健康职业生涯中迈出下一步，请查看“有抱负的心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership），我们在那里做着很棒的事情，研究研究、认知行为疗法、反思、面试技巧、申请技巧等等。
If you found this episode interesting, don't forget to like, subscribe, share it with others who also love diving into the iconic psychology studies and learning more about the way that we understand the world today and how we've understood it in the past. If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book.
如果你觉得这一集很有趣，别忘了点赞、订阅并分享给其他同样喜欢深入研究经典心理学研究、了解我们今天如何理解世界以及过去如何理解世界的人。如果你想成为一名心理学家，让这成为你的指南。有这个播客在身边，你将走上获得资格的道路。这是Marianne Trent博士的《有抱负的心理学家播客》。我叫Jana，是一名心理健康从业者实习生。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。
I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself. So if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。我惊讶于达到这一目标的途径竟然如此之多，没有完美的途径，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得自己在做错什么，也减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。